this is Startalk welcome back to
Startalk we're in the how tweeted is
section it's great to be here yeah the
lab health helping me out here
bill tweet said Bill Nye yep and I
follow you Bill but thank you I follow
you knew I follow so this part we just
explored tweets I posted in reactions to
them and what my thinking was and I'd
welcome your feedback on one of them
that I posted back the February 2015
good education is not what fills your
heads with facts but what stimulates
curiosity then you learn for the rest of
your life like wow are you can I get an
amen on that you can get an amen all
right keep in mind but some point you
have to learn the alphabet no but you do
come pucker give me the D no every lead
state capitals are not clear not not not
really I don't think or trig identities
or how about Patrick I to forty or fifty
or a hundred digits worse your son up to
right now seventeen yet he's 70 yeah is
that useful not 76 does give you
perspective yeah plus is bragging rights
in the in the middle in the nerd land
yeah but then we go on to say that there
is something to it the more trivia
you know I claim the more you know like
it's hard to remember trivia unless you
have a framework on which to hang those
facts
oh and so the answer to me is not one or
the other you've got to learn to think
and you got to know things to think
about and the framework is the perhaps
the wisdom and on that wisdom the facts
adorn this is Startalk
[Music]